Now that you've got
a solid foundation of the different components that will make up our data model,
let's talk about gathering your data sources with
colleagues and then discuss how you can think through the restructuring.
We've already talked through how important it is to get
feedback from subject matter experts when planning a report.
Let's get back to that meeting I took without you when we
started building the intuition exercise.
Some of the questions that I would have asked,
and that you should too in future meetings like this,
are meant to help us define the structure of the data model.
Things like what key data needs to be calculated in
the report helps us know what the facts are that we should include in our fact table.
How is the data grouped or filtered?
This gives us a clue in terms of what kind of dimensions that we need,
and if perhaps we need to work with them to create
our own groupings on the dimension table to facilitate special reporting needs.
The data can support,
but we'll need a little bit of additional logic to make possible.
Next, from where can we access the data?
This will help us to find our data sources,
and it will also ensure that we're not trying to build
something where there isn't a data source available.
Do we need access rights?
This is an often forgotten but critical question to ask.
For example, a SQL database connection string might be something you can get easily,
but it doesn't do you any good if you can't also obtain the appropriate permissions.
This is where the suggestion I made earlier to
ask for read only access can often be helpful in obtaining this.
Is there any sensitive data that we need to take care not to pull into the data model?
Security settings are outside the scope of this course,
but one way you can avoid needing to address them in the first place,
is to take care to avoid pulling in
any fields to your data model that contains sensitive information.
Finally, can we rely on the data?
If your subject matter experts are telling you that you can access the data from
somewhere but they don't trust it all the way to be reliable information,
this may not be the right time for this report to be made.
However, if the situation is that there are certain
known consistent errors that can be addressed holistically in the data set,
this is something we can do in Power Query and that we'll cover in an upcoming video.
In an ideal scenario,
you'll leave this kind of meeting with a list of
sources and a sense of what's available in each.
From there, you would review these sources to confirm they will all work in Power BI,
and then start thinking through you can transform it into what you need.
Luckily, there are a wide range of sources that
have custom connections already in Power BI,
and there are additional ways you can enable connections if for whatever reason,
what you need isn't readily available.
Power Query also gives you plenty of options for how we can
adjust information without impacting the source data itself.
You're certainly not locked in to the initial structure just because it's how it arrived.
There are many ways to transform data to get it how you need it to be.
If you can logically explain how you'd want the data
to change based on how it exists currently,
and if those changes can be applied across an entire column,
you're generally going to be able to make those changes using Power Query.
Despite all this freedom,
there are a few things you can't do.
One, you can't reference just one cell in Power Query or
Power BI in general because cells aren't really a thing in this technology.
When a transformation occurs,
it's generally across values in an entire column in the table.
Two, you can't create a report with data that doesn't exist.
I refer to this as vapor data.
Often folks just assume that data that would be useful must exist somewhere.
The reality, of course,
is that data doesn't exist unless someone took the time to track and maintain it.
Unfortunately, potentially useful data
often isn't tracked until someone decides that they want some kind of report on it.
It can be a bit of a catch-22.